well there are two immediate ones in one
longer term that that have really
grabbed my attention one is the
situation of Pakistan we have just
fought a Great War under the illusion
that Iraq had WMD and we're still
engaged in that struggle if Pakistan is
not successful in enlightened moderation
you could have 162 million Pakistanis
with nuclear weapons and delivery
systems and that would dramatically
change the equation to lesser extent I'm
concerned with the developments in Iran
and their search for nuclear weapons the
longer term thing that has got my be
concerned is that we are so focused on
Iraq and to the lesser extent
Afghanistan and I think we're
overlooking our longer-term equities
which are in Asia by every measure the
largest countries in the world of
biggest GDPs the world the largest
militaries the greatest thirst for
energy the greatest hunger for raw
materials they're all there in Asia and
this is where the future of our country
lives but because of our myopia in the
Middle East we're not able I think to
really position ourselves well yet
they're an ally I think in the fight
against Al Qaeda there's no question of
that there are mixed views in Pakistan
about the the Taliban and there's a
different scene I think in many corners
of Iraq between Al Qaeda who were
foreigners and Taliban who are primarily
pashtoon if not exclusively pashtoon a
large tribe in at Pakistan as well so
the answer is there an ally sometimes
and they were worried sometimes